Hunger's a huge problem in the greater Boston
area, there are estimates and studies that
indicate that about one in 10 people are food
insecure in the area, and then of course in
different populations, that number can be
quite a bit higher.
There are hungry people all over, so it's
a huge problem, and we're trying to do a little
bit to help it with this program.
We have 14 different dining facilities and
our students are under a mandatory meal plan,
we have to be prepared to feed the numbers
that come in.
In this business, we're bound to have food
leftover so we're just looking for a good
way to be able to take that food and put it
to good use.
Food for Free is a food, rescue, and hunger
relief organization, we bridge the gap between
waste and want.
One one side of the equation, there's a lot
of extra food out there, and on the other
side there's a lot of hungry people, and we
help connect the two.
Two nights a week, a team of student volunteers,
they're taking the leftover food from service
for the day and playing it up into meals.
They use a serving of grains, a serving of
protein, and a serving of vegetables, seal
them up, label them, put them in their freezer,
and then, our trucks come and pick them up
a couple times a week, and we get them out
to the families that need them.
So Harvard students come in a group with a
bunch of other students and I think from their
perspective, it's a great way for them to
interact with the D-hall staff then also sort
of talk to each other and interact while they're
sort of creating this food, so it's a way
for students to get to know their local D-hall
staff, it's a way for students to create a
tangible result, and it's also a way for students
to reach out to the local community, in like
a very convenient way.
I think most students have really enjoyed
the experience that they've had with the family
meals program, there's a lot of people coming
away smiling, and sort of, happily taking
a picture, so I think a lot of people get
a lot out of it, and I've had a lot of people
ask if they can come again.